[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
George - town that was unacceptable
today you got a lovely mix it up John I
get bored you can mix it up but you
can't go that far norm hello and welcome
to dear Hank and John nor as I prefer to
think of it Dear John and Hank it's a
comedy podcast where two brothers answer
your questions give YouTube you said of
icing bring you all the week's news from
both Mars and AFC Wimbledon John what is
the elephant in the room before we get
to the elephant in the room can we get
to the elephant that is your weirdly
affected voice I don't know I feel like
people want to hear something a little
different to start the podcast and now
I'm gonna be normal for the rest of
podcast that was just that thing well
I'm sorry John I tried to become a
professional voice actor - the only
thing that's important to me anymore and
I don't like you stepping all over my
dreams when you have an affectation in
your voice it takes me right back to
that terrible terrible no I know
nope let's not even talk about it danger
when you faked a British accent for six
months in high school Hank what is the
elephant in the room three two one
climate change climate change climate
change John oh no hey climate change is
a long-term problem and therefore one
that we don't have to deal with but it's
such a big problem and it's grey and
it's got a trunk and four feet so you
think it's the elephant in the room oh I
see I see it took me a second I was like
so climate change is an elephant I'd
already moved on yeah I I was talking to
the old head of the EPA so the issue
Gina McCarthy was the head of the EPA
under Barack Obama for the last from
like 2013 to 2017 and she's lovely and
wonderful and I just had a great chat
with her and it made me feel kind of
more sort of like viscerally connected
to the idea of
this long-term problem that's going to
significantly affect people's lives and
health and success as humans over the
next forever and I also feel a little
bit more optimistic about it honestly so
I enjoyed that a lot and I think that I
I think that I think that we got a big
ole elephant John and his name is not
Michael Cohen because I think that long
after we're worried about Michael Cohen
not anymore we will still be worried
about the climate being different oh
yeah for sure I didn't mean to imply
that Michael Cohen is the biggest
problem facing humans that is definitely
a climate change followed by maybe
global pandemic which will in part
because by climate change so yeah I I
didn't mean to imply that I thought that
we were still a weekly comedy podcast I
didn't realize that we'd become a
podcast exploring the biggest problems
facing humans if so we should rename
this dear climate and change that's good
Jonathan that's got a really strong ring
to it and people would definitely listen
to that it is weird to me that climate
change is such a politically sensitive
topic it's not weird to me it is noted
to me you know it's weird to me is that
on my Google News site that I opened up
to try and figure out what the elephant
in the room was going to be before
resorting to climate change
it says Missoula weather thunderstorm
seventy degrees Fahrenheit and then I
can change the from 70 degrees
Fahrenheit to Celsius I could also
change to Kelvin that is exciting that
doesn't seem like a thing that's
necessary do I need to know that it's
294 degrees K oh sorry not degrees
people will get mad at you when you say
degrees Kelvin because they're not
degrees 294 Kelvin outside I don't feel
like I need to know that well Hank just
as you don't need to know how many
kelvins it is outside I don't need to
know the details of Michael Cohen's life
and yet for some reason I know all of
them this uh this elephant in the room
seems to be fairly present do you know
what the phrase elephant in the room
means yeah I think that you don't know
what the phrase elephant in the room
sorry I've got a Google first I have to
let you know that that on Friday it's
gonna get up to 303 Kelvin so just so
you know that oh that's exciting
congratulations to you guys this era of
fire risk at 303 degrees Kelvin or is
that like almost absolute zero because I
have no idea yeah it sounds like there
would be an elephant in the room you
mean that there's an obvious problem or
difficult situation that people do not
want to talk about I always thought that
it was that no one is talking about no
it's that people are uncomfortable
talking about the way that you know
nobody on TV or in political podcasts or
on political radio is talking about
Michael Cohen nobody wants to talk about
it nobody wants to talk about that at
all obviously that's why no one's
talking about it anywhere come to think
of it climate change is a significantly
better elephant in the room than Michael
Cohen who's more like the elephant in
the room that everyone is like hey guys
have you noticed that there's an
elephant in this room let's talk about
it okay I want to spend a few minutes
thinking about something other than
Michael Cohen so let's get to some
questions from our listeners this first
one comes from Alex who writes dear John
and Hank my best friend ended up with
extra concert tickets so decided to give
me one for my birthday I feel like this
gift is a bit of an afterthought and I
can't decide whether to go I really want
to see the artist performing but I would
have to fly to her city which isn't
cheap at a very busy time in the school
year for me and also I would be seated
by myself in a different section from
her and her other friends which again
makes me feel like an afterthought
should I go Alex no no you know say oh
that's really thoughtful Sandra I
appreciate that so much
but like absolutely I got so much going
on here in Birmingham Alabama where I
live you know what about Alex I can't I
get out to Bellevue Washington to see
Taylor Swift perform in a different a
seat that is nowhere near your seat
yes I'm instead going to
spend time doing lots of cool things
that are also very cool
I completely agree Hank that is the
appropriate response to that extremely
passive-aggressive birthday present the
thing that like if I'm having a friend
fly out and I'm like and I've got like
local friends that are sitting near me
no the local friends go sit in the Rando
seat my friend who flew on a plane to
come see me is gonna sit in my section
but even then I wouldn't go you got
other things going on it's a busy time
in the school year and you're not gonna
buy a plane ticket to go see well maybe
concert tickets these days are
exorbitant I don't understand how this
happens people are paying four figures
to go see a Paul brother I don't know
what's going on
I'm saying also the cost of Paul brother
tickets think that we've been under
charging all of these years charging
like 10 or 20 bucks for a gig but that
still seems reasonable to me it seems
expensive 20 dollars it's quite
expensive it's more than I didn't want
to ask but it is the necessary cost to
make the event work exactly
speaking of which Hank is going on tour
are you ready to announce your tour yet
nope but I figure to go on tour it's
true this is a true fact and I will if
you were hoping that I go to a place
that is not in America or doesn't have a
ton of people
you'll probably be disappointed because
the publishing company wants me to go to
the places where the people are I
apologize being a person who is from a
place where there are not very many
people I understand your plight Hank
astonishingly that question from Alex
was not the most troubling question we
received this week about birthday
presents instead that discussion goes to
Abby who writes dear John and Hank on
the need of dubious advice I
accidentally found out what my boyfriend
is giving me for my birthday due to
Amazon shipment notifications not from
snooping and I don't want it it's a
countertop dishwasher well I think these
are great we've discussed buying one in
the past and decided not to because of a
lack of counter space in our 400 square
foot studio apartment also he knows the
dishes and I do the cooking so this is
really a gift for him rather than
me what do I do i nonchalantly hint that
I don't want one do I wait until I open
it do I say nothing and tolerate an
object that will inconvenience and annoy
me advice needed sometimes crabby Abby
you know Abby I think ultimately we're
probably gonna open that present and
just in like and then put it on the
counter and just see about it
perpetually but that isn't the healthy
thing to do that's just the thing that
normal we people would do now if if this
is coming in time and of course it isn't
because amazon is extremely fast with
its shipping so it's probably already
arrived you've already been through this
situation and 17 months have passed
because that's how fast Prime is and
it's very difficult to compete with as a
person who runs an e-commerce store but
then we're getting off topic calm
descending you packages much much more
slowly than Amazon the problem is that
you've already received the shipment
notification so there's nothing you
can't send it back you can't have it not
arrived because what like ultimately the
best option would just be like to be
like oh I don't know Andrew you the
thing never arrived you bought it but
Amazon decided not to send it it seems
as if it got cancelled mysteriously by
me they must have known that as
previously discussed I don't want to
countertop dishwasher we actually have a
phrase for this in our family when you
give someone a gift that is really for
you we call it a homer present because
in an episode of The Simpsons Homer gave
Marge a bowling ball that was drilled to
his fingers and this feels to me very
much like a Homer present which in our
marriage anyway you're only allowed to
do if you acknowledge it and if it's not
gonna be something that annoys the other
person so yeah I think you have to have
a conversation and the bummer here is
that you are gonna hurt your significant
others feelings they probably don't
remember that conversation they probably
think that you want this they probably
remember it differently from how you do
and so there is there are gonna be some
hurt feelings but you can't in a 400
square foot apartment I've lived in that
apartment
not that exact one a V I don't think
although I guess it's possible I've
lived in an apartment of that size and
like
you cannot have an object in that
apartment that annoys you because you
see it all the time
yeah it's gonna end like and every time
you want to put down the macaroni and
cheese on a place you're gonna be like
where's the place well it would have
been here if it were a Andrew and his
frickin countertop dishwasher that was
supposed to be a present for me do you
know it was supposed to be a present for
you could it be possible he's just
buying it for himself to do is there
like a a notification that said like
birthday present for Abby like in the
shipment notification great point Hank
Abby what you say is I saw the shift in
notification and it doesn't make any
sense because we discussed the
countertop dishwasher and I don't want
one and then you don't even know it's a
birthday present it's right unless it
said like happy birthday AB don't know I
don't know where Amazon will send those
notes for free overnight anyway go to
dftba.com for all of your e-commerce
minutes this next question comes from
Ali who asks dear Hank and John my name
is Ali and recently per your
recommendation I went to the aunts
Canada YouTube channel on a related note
I have discovered that I have a fear of
ant colonies why would anyone find an
colony is enjoyable I genuinely want to
know the interest others have in them
since my newly discovered phobia refuses
to allow me to appreciate them please
don't antagonize me for this question
Ally John I love ant colony so much but
I understand that different people are
gonna like different things and that's
mostly the only thing I wanted to say
about this though just because you don't
appreciate something doesn't mean that
you that I'm gonna like you less cuz you
don't appreciate something that I like
and it doesn't mean that I want you to
appreciate something or that it
decreases my appreciation for it just
cuz not everybody in the world is into
the same things ants Canada is a really
good YouTube channel to return to my
childhood I also had a phrase about this
when I was a younger person hmm the
phrase was don't harsh on my buzz
right yeah Donna harsh on - yeah of
course of course I'm yeah but that's not
what they say these days the kids that
the kids say don't you
anybody's yums oh they don't this is
that really what they say yeah I don't
yep people's yums hug I grow old I grow
old I shall wear the bottoms of my
trousers rolled but yeah yeah we used to
say don't harsh on my buzz and like in
general I feel the same way to be honest
like I don't really get
a fascination with ant colonies I don't
mind an individual ant because it's just
doing its thing no it's just my it's
just trying to make its way in the world
just like I am but when I see like
millions of ants and like no that's not
for me but I'm not gonna harsh on your
buzz Hank I think it's great that you
like ants Canada and I like watching
this fictional soccer team created by
dr. Benjy FM play every day so we've all
got our hobbies and let's not harsh on
each other's yums I feel so bad for the
individual ant I feel like an individual
ant is nothing it's the same way I feel
about an individual human we're nothing
without our colonies John and and in the
same way that I imagine one might feel
about ants crawling I'll move for each
other in a colony being this sort of
like weird gross hive mind I imagine
people who aren't humans looking down
upon earth thinking maybe a little bit
the same thing about our teeming mass of
human flesh that has so effectively
taken over this planet comedy podcast
John you got a question for me because
we need to move on this question comes
from Laura who writes Dear John and Hank
why did Hank just make me have to think
about a teeming mass of humans being
observed from on high I apologize Laura
I and I apologize to everybody out there
I just think a lot about what we look
like from the outside and I don't think
that and in the same way that I love ant
colonies I think that I think that a
race of sentient beings observing us
would think wow look at them they're not
doing it perfect but they're doing it
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know what I actually think a species
of sentient beings would say about us
man they have a lot of cows Jesus look
at all these cows that they have oh man
there's a like some disturbing
percentage of the number of mammals on
earth a cows yeah well I do know that
of all the mammal like flesh combined on
earth if you combine the human with the
cow that's a majority oh wow
I also know that the majority of birds
on the planet are poultry which is a
crazy stack oh my god alright this next
question comes from Jess who writes dear
John and Hank my husband and I listen to
your podcast every time we do the dishes
Jess have you considered a countertop
dishwasher we recently saw John and a
live podcast thing with Andrew Luck
who's the quarterback of the Colts and a
lovely person and it was a little
surreal to hear your voice without
having dishwater hands it was all so
surreal for me to be hanging out with
the quarterback of the Indianapolis
Colts my question is about a situation I
find myself in often what do you do if
you're interrupted when you're beginning
to talk does the loudest person get to
go first no you just skip ahead and keep
your story to yourself Hank I'm trying
to talk or do you jump back to your
story even if the conversation has moved
on I tend to be a chatty person who
likes to tell stories but I don't ever
want to be commanding of conversation so
I'd love to hear any advice thanks for
all of it the things you do I mean Jess
I like to be I like to let the quietest
person go if I am in control at all of
the conversation is this something that
I've been trying to do for the last like
10 years to identify the person who
tried to talk and was not able to and
shut up because I'm loud and also tall
and also you know often the boss in the
room if I can work situations and so I
do do my best to try and not be the step
over or and I think that conversational
dominance is a problem that that a lot
of like people have and that they
sometimes can see it as not a problem
but as like a an attribute like
something that they're got a little bit
proud of and I'm just like yeah but I
have the problem of like you have this
thing that you wanted to say this very
good story that fit very welcome to the
conversation but then the conversation
moves on without your story and you're
like but I've had a good one
and for that I get
phone and I write it in a note and I
save it there and I'm like I could tell
that story some other time maybe to
Twitter or something
wait in the middle of a conversation
you're like excuse me the conversation
has moved on past the story that I
wanted to tell so I'm now going to get
out my phone and write the story in a
note I I have established among my the
first of all I like a two-person
conversation if it was a two-person
conversation I could get my story and
I'm talking about in the situation where
there's like six people talking this
always happens to me where I just like I
had Oh when there's a bunch of and it's
just such it's hard it's hard to
communicate in that way and when there's
six people talking but he's like oh he's
texting his wife or something I don't
love it but I support you and I'm not
gonna harsh on your buzz that's my new
policy I'm not gonna harsh on your yums
enjoy your yums man this next question
comes from Carr who writes Dear John and
Hank memorial benches they seem weird
what am I supposed to do it at them well
I mean that if not you're supposed to
sit on the man about what you were
thinking about doing with them okay my
supposed to throw them into the ocean
we're supposed to like get a hacksaw
remove it and then take it to my house
and build a flower shrine around it I'm
supposed to bury this memory of a person
just as their body was buried what do I
do with this bench do I only this
anointing just like rub it with
eucalyptus is that what happens do I
need to like bring a candle and hate it
and sit next to the candle and think
about James yeah there's actually a rule
you're not supposed to say it on a
memorial bench while wearing pants you
point with human butts that's true
you're not truly honoring Gladys's
memory if you're wearing pants it's just
how it is I feel so strongly that one
should never sit on any bench unless one
is wearing pants that I don't know that
I'm able to move on with the rest of the
question until you establish that you're
making a joke I don't think that you
should sit on anything except a toilet
seat
while not wearing pants like I like the
idea of sitting on like a leather couch
naked it's just the worst thought that I
can imagine like oh you like once you're
there you can't move ever again because
there's no shifting allowed is it okay
to sit on a bench that says in memory of
James a devoted father and friend it
feels like I'm sitting on a tombstone
which is obviously not okay right that
that's right Cara it's not okay to sit
on a tombstone at least it's not a
tombstone or somebody you know I well at
least at least unless it's a tombstone
of someone you knew but then again
Carrie writes if I don't sit on them am
i dishonouring the person because
obviously they like sitting there and
looking at the view and they wanted
others to do the same right right I used
to be worried about finding a name
specific sign-off but now I don't
kara well I was calling her Cara earlier
but obviously it's Cara it's just that I
am personally acquainted with a Cara and
so I'm sorry for mispronouncing your
name earlier cara cara sit on the bench
sit on the bench not only that now you
have to sit on every bench because
otherwise you're not honor you like
walking past that bench and saying I
don't care about your view yeah
GLaDOS I don't care about you James or
no somebody made that gift to support a
park service or to support a trail or
whatever because the person they are
honoring probably liked being there
right because they didn't you to take a
moment out of your day to just think of
that person's name I
there's a saying at 99% invisible always
read the plaque mmm I love that saying
and it reminds you to pay attention when
you have the opportunity to because you
might discover something surprising or
interesting and I love memorial benches
because it's an opportunity to read the
plaque now the question then becomes
John yeah what is the smallest amount of
time you can sit on the bench while
properly honoring the memory of the
person's so if there's a lot of benches
and each of them is honoring a different
person who it's not like slide my butt
over
each one a little bit to sort of say hey
thanks for the bench I mean I would
submit that you and Karen might be
overthinking this a little bit that when
you want to sit on a bench you should
and you don't want to sit on a bench you
shouldn't and that it's one of the very
few things in life that's reasonably cut
and dry like in a world of confusing
grays and conflicting ethical
responsibilities it seems to me that
like choosing whether to sit is one of
the cleanest clearest choices that we
have and please God let us hold on to it
as long as possible this next question
comes from Ashley who asks dear Hank and
John I've been living a lie when I made
my first Instagram back in high school
my first name last name was already
taken so I met up a new but similar a
last name for myself which was available
and that is still my current Instagram
name however I'm now 23 and I've moved
to England and I'm working as a
freelance stylist I use my Instagram to
network and get jobs now every one of my
professional life knows be my my fake
instagram name and keeping up
appearances is getting out of hand my
website email address official business
name and substantial number of magazine
credits are in my fake name I don't mind
the fake name so this should be find
except when people pay me my invoices or
they're booking me for a flight they see
my real name and it makes me look shady
AF what should I do
should I just change my name to my fake
name to avoid confusion should I stop
the charade and come clean dubious
advice is greatly appreciated faking it
till I make it Ashley very apt I also
have to make people send checks to a
name that they don't know but it's my
first name and people kind of get that I
think a little bit more than the last
name and I do like I do kind of feel
like what what are you trying to hide
Ashley what if I google your real name
but also I'm like maybe this is a
strategy that everyone should be using
so that it's harder to Facebook people
yeah I think you can just say that I
think you can just say I work under a
different name
then my facebook name or my birth
certificate name because of privacy and
because I'm you know have these two
separate lives it
just made me think Hank how screwed
would I be if I had to live by my first
usernames oh gosh
yeah I'd be a real problem what was your
do you remember your first usernames
because mine were like properly
humiliating and I often think like if we
had grown up in the YouTube era when
people really are stuck with their like
17 year old or 15 year old usernames a
lot of times I would be totally hosed
mm-hmm
yeah I remember mine my very first one
on CompuServe was K - 9 which is the
name of Doctor Who's dog but people
would always assumed I was a Kathryn
because that's short for K and then I
think that after that sure that the high
school middle school one was Sir Spanky
G yes
oh yeah that's bad mine was in middle
school it was P stank peace danged P
stanky stank
I think the so like Sir Spanky G has a
certain amount of like yes that's
extremely humiliating but like at least
that guy wasn't taking himself seriously
yeah exact know my usernames were always
this will not surprise you in any way
extremely serious and then when I was in
high school and I started having like on
an online crush my username was and this
is it was eskimo kisses oh no John
that's you're adorable this next
question comes from Sarah who asks dear
Hank and John I'm thinking I'm being
followed by a hawk this all started
three days ago when this hawk was
sitting on the fence by the front of my
car they just stared at me and didn't
move at all as I got into my car later
when I was at work which is a mile from
my work there was a hawk circling over
my car I keep seeing it on that fence in
the morning and just now as I'm leaving
work the hawk was on my car just sitting
there should I feed it should I talk to
it am I being summoned on some kind of
life-changing cosmic adventure
and he
help would be greatly appreciated being
watched by a hawk Sara you got to get a
hawk tattoo I mean I don't know a
hundred percent but I feel like you got
to get a hawk tattoo my feeling about
this is that it's one of those times
when it's really helpful to believe that
humans can live inside of hawk spirits
or whatever because maybe you could just
be like oh it's my grandpa he did always
like hawks and then you could just be
like random cars thank you for visiting
me and I release you from this world and
then maybe the hawk will stop visiting
you but if you don't believe that then
it probably won't help but that's one
reason why you should believe that your
grandpa turned into a hawk oh yeah I
like the idea of just like walking down
the street and seeing a person talking
to a hawk that's sitting on their car
and saying I release you I go free
grandpa mostly mostly I like it if the
hawk just keeps coming back keep doing
that so that people can watch that
happen as often as possible and and
maybe wait until somebody is about 20 30
feet away before you start talking to
the hawk so that they can experience the
full the full dramatic endeavor I
actually think that according to Hawk
law Sara and this hawk are now married
oh that's totally possible which reminds
me John that this podcast is actually
brought to you by hawk law Hawk law not
a particularly easy thing to say the
rural juror of animal laws today's flag
has also brought defy passive aggressive
concert tickets passive aggressive
concert tickets oh no yeah please come
see Bruno Mars with me don't sit with me
and you have to fly here this podcast
has also brought to you by an individual
ant an individual ant not disturbing and
probably screwed because they don't do
well on their own and finally in today's
podcast is brought to you by James's
bench James's bench just pause and
remember him while wearing pants while
wearing pants this podcast also has an
axe
will sponsor John our actual sponsor for
the day is brilliant org so you are a
human being
person listening to this also John did
you know that the meaning of life is in
part like working to get better at stuff
and having skills and abilities that can
be used in versatile situations to make
life better for yourself and other
people and also that that isn't just
something that's good to do but is also
like fun brilliant org gives me a chance
to do this I like brilliant odd org
because it gives me a chance to do
things that aren't Twitter and that
instead make my mind better it thinks
that it was just recently worse at which
could be anything from probability logic
complex algebra physics astronomy
machine learning computer science all
that stuff and I don't feel ashamed when
I'm learning something new and brilliant
because when I get something wrong only
I know that it happened and the little
descriptions don't judge me they just
tell me how I got confused and they're
right because it's normal to get
confused when you're learning something
new and developing more correct
intuitions about the world it's also
valuable and fun to get better at stuff
so if you want to support dear Hank and
John and learn more about brilliant go -
brilliant - dear Hank and sign up for
free and also the first 200 people to go
to that link will get 20% off the annual
premium subscription and the premium
product is really really good I have to
say you can also go to brilliant org
slash Dear John brilliant is science and
math in Richmond learning and it is
really really wonderful so go over to
brilliant org slash dear John dear Hank
also works and check out brilliant org
thanks to them for sponsoring today's
bob this next question comes to you from
Laura who asks dear Hank and John I'm a
server at a pizza place and I have to
close the restaurant a lot how do I deal
with guests who come in 30 minutes
before closing time technically we are
open but I can't help looking at those
people who come in like their only
purpose is to keep me there that extra
hour I sometimes just want to tell them
to go but I feel like that would be
really rude any dubious suggestions to
get them to go would be greatly
appreciated is serving with a fake smile
Laura yeah your if we were a server once
upon a time John I've never had that job
but I have had those situations where
I'm like please please please if one
thing doesn't happen and
five minutes then it will be over but if
it does happen then I will keep it this
thing that I don't like will keep
happening for a long time right I did
work at a 24-hour restaurant so it was a
little bit different fine I also wasn't
hungry as good of an employee as Laura
is so frequently when people would come
to the 24-hour restaurant where I worked
and for whatever reason I didn't want to
serve them I would say our grill is
broken and then they would leave we're
out of cheese we ran out we ran out of
cheese so if you want to if you want a
bread if you don't like wet bread we
could do that fun I'm not going to be
able to give you a hamburger so I guess
it's up to you want a coke I could get
you a just a couple on the street
they're pretty good they're theirs it
tastes great even late so uh yeah I mean
Laura I don't think there's anything
wrong with explaining to someone who
shows up at the last minute or 30
minutes before closing we close in 30
minutes I'm happy to make you a pizza
bite I'm gonna be you know just so you
know I'm gonna be getting everything
ready around you I'm gonna be doing my
side work I'm gonna be sweeping and
mopping and putting up the chairs and
everything I don't think there's
anything wrong with doing side work
frankly like when I go to a pizza
restaurant or any restaurant near
closing time I expect I understand that
as part of the contract of people making
me food close to the end of their work
time I will not eat in a way that makes
this go on unnecessarily long like I'll
eat quickly and try not to have many
crumbs and so I don't know I don't think
there's a thing wrong with items sure
restaurant owners will vehement ly
disagree with me but I don't think
there's anything wrong with just ya
planning to people look the kitchens
about to close and you know hustle
mm-hmm yeah and I think it is sort of
like a weirdness in the contract of of
of like sit down dining it's like the
restaurant closes it's at 9:00 and so I
should be able to get there at 8:00
Denine and do my dining thing but also
no you can't like it doesn't work that
way and I don't think it's immediately
obvious to people who haven't worked in
in a restaurant setting that that is the
situation and so I think it makes
perfect sense to explain explain that
that it's like this is the time at which
like we lot like we close the doors and
people aren't in the restaurant anymore
so if you're gonna eat well I'll have to
do it fast alternately you ran out of
cheese yeah
it's just like yeah and also the oven
breaking of things that people who don't
work in restaurants might not know if
you ever find yourself at a Steak and
Shake at 4:30 in the morning and someone
tells you that the grill is down you're
just drunk and they don't want to serve
you food or I think this next question
comes from show trick who writes Dear
John and Hank I like to read and
sometimes after finishing a good book I
get too excited and give an enthusiastic
review god forbid after days when the
initial excitement has ebbed I find
myself wondering if I should have been
less generous with my words what is the
recommended amount of time one should
wait before reviewing a book or movie or
any product for that matter no trick
show trick no no and when do I ever
think to myself boy I wish I'd been less
generous with my words
maybe when you're on Goodreads and
people are judging you for your 5 star
reviews and telling you that the books
that you gave 5 stars to didn't deserve
5 stars what they're doing is harshing
on your yums stop it and don't let
people harsh on your yums
you like the book when you read it
that's great thank God in this broken
world you found something that gave you
comfort and made you feel less alone
hooray don't let anybody judge your five
star reviews.i
authors are very grateful for your five
star reviews so if you like a book or a
movie I don't think that you should I
don't think you should wait until after
the afterglow passes to be like well
upon further reflection maybe I didn't
like it as much as I liked it while I
was reading it yeah I I mean I often
find that that like two weeks later I'm
less excited about a book because I'm
not reading it you know Mike not in the
in the world I'm and and like my
enthusiasm for a thing isn't gonna last
forever but that doesn't mean that like
I didn't
really enjoy that experience and that
feeling that I had at the end was a real
feeling and I arrived that feeling so
much and and part of why I read is so
that I can have it more and sometimes
when I finish a book I don't have that
feeling I didn't love the book and then
I then I don't I don't tend to leave a
review at all honestly when that happens
but I yeah but but I'm always searching
for it and I think it's a good to
celebrated and not I call it not real
just because it didn't last forever
instead I would recommend with those
books that do get better upon further
appraisal or get better the more
distance you have from them I might
recommend going back and editing your
review to say unlike a lot of books this
one has really stayed with me and here's
what has stayed with me mm-hmm and I I
even have done that to authors on
Twitter where I will say like you know
like I read your book two weeks ago and
I've been thinking about it ever since
and that means like that's the kind of
thing that like having seen and known
authors I know like matters a lot and
yeah and and I think that like for big
hard creative projects like book writing
it like that kind of support
is surprisingly necessary fuel oh yeah
absolutely
and also if you live in a review for an
absolutely remarkable thing after you
read it comes out September 25th it's
available for pre-order now definitely
leave that review the moment you feel
best about the book so whenever that is
like save whatever it is I'm so excited
for people to read your book it
definitely gave me that feeling like
that book hangover feeling where you
want to live in the world for longer and
hang out with those people more but it
also has stuck with me and really
reshaped the way I think about a lot of
things that are important to me so I
think yeah I mean congrat it's just it's
so good it's so freakin good yeah you
can't but if you keep saying it's gonna
start wearing off so you guys you gotta
like only only plug it like every fourth
pod it's how it works okay I will try to
only plug it every fourth pod even
though I don't think that that's
necessarily good marketing this next
question comes from Rebecca who writes
to whom it may
where do bugs go when it rains P and P
odd which means pumpkins and penguins
Rebecca
Pride and Prejudice Rebecca they they
depends on the bug like a lot of bugs
live underwater so they don't even know
you know never rains underwater it never
rains underwater get that tattoo that is
a very bad tattoo idea I don't want to
but that is not a good tattoo
recommendation it definitely means
something I can't tell you what it means
but it's got a deep metaphorical
residence for something I mean I'm not
convinced of that but Hank more to the
point where do bugs go when it rains
they hang out under leaves or something
or do they just yeah actually some some
do hang out under leaves butterflies
particularly will hide under under
leaves because they can be damaged by
rain if they get hit by big drops or if
they get too wet it slows them down and
they cool off and and lose some of their
heat which is a big deal so yeah a lot
of a lot of bugs but beetles tend to be
okay they tend to not mind getting wet
especially if like they have a sheath
that covers their wings they tend to be
better about that a lot of animals I
mean it depends on the level of rain
some animals love it when it gets wet
and like come out specifically when it's
wet so yeah I mean it depends on the bug
but but yeah flying bugs that can't
sheath their wings tend to hide they go
under things they go under leaves or
logs or something like that that is also
my response to rain him yeah hide go
with to a place where it's not I'm not
being hit by the rain I was just in
Florida and it rained so much while I
was there and I loved it a lot and I did
not think that I would and everybody
kept apologizing for the fact that it
was a really rainy week and I was like
actually I just like want to be getting
rained on right now like be out an
85-degree weather getting like not
having to swim to get wet it's great
cooling off yeah I mean I think I think
that maybe speaks to a certain amount of
nostalgia for our childhood which was
spent in Florida and therefore
frequently wet in afternoon
thunderstorms Hank before we get to the
all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon we
to read a couple of very important
responses first off you and I speculated
about the nature of the bird and the
famous Emily Dickinson poem hope is the
thing with feathers and Colin wrote in
with a fantastic reading that has blown
my mind Dear John and Hank a couple of
podcasts ago someone asked what kind of
bird hope is in that Emily Dickinson can
I make a guess can I make a guy yeah
real quick I haven't read this yet is it
my grandpa as a hawk no is that your
phrase of the week no I'll be really
good one it would be very elegantly I'd
heard that it's a pun on the Latin for I
hope spero a sparrow but neither of you
sentence disclaimer I don't have an
English degree Colin Colin you are 100%
right it has to be a sparrow
it is a sparrow hope is a sparrow
it has been decided right now right here
because of the Latin for I hope there's
no way Emily Dickinson didn't know that
and she wasn't making that beautiful and
very deeply meaningful pun also Hank we
talked last episode about the fact that
we both think that Greece too is the
canonical Greece movie and that Greece 1
is some kind of third-rate prequel and
it turns out we are not the only people
who believed this there are a number of
people all of them approximately our age
who also experience to to be the one
true Greece including Julie who wrote in
to say Dear John and Hank I am almost 40
years old and Greece 2 is my favorite
Greece movie I too thought it was the
only Greece movie until I was in my late
teens I suspect Greece too was
inexpensive to rerun on TV hence our
overexposure Greece with John Travolta
is overrated your oldest fan no way
Julie not even close not even close for
one thing I'm a fan of Hank and I'm 40
[Laughter]
you're only 40 I mean I almost said but
then I realized they can't say that on
the plot what's the news from Mars John
it feels like we made it been a while
since we made a podcast because there's
been this excellent Mars news but I
haven't been able to talk to it first
for some time but the Mars 2020 Rover
scheduled to launch in 2020 hasn't been
named yet it's gonna have a better name
than 2020 when it launches it's gonna be
very similar to the Curiosity rover but
it has just been approved to have
included on it a tiny little drone
helicopter that will separate and fly
off of the hell of the of the rover and
go do science autonomously separately
which is very cool that they're gonna
have a helicopter on Mars John that is
pretty exciting I can't believe there's
gonna be a helicopter on Mars is it
gonna be like the drones that we have
where the battery lasts for like 14
minutes it's gonna have a little solar
panel on it so it'll be able to recharge
it certainly won't be able to fly
continuously on the solar charge but it
will land rest recharge its batteries
and then I'll be able to fly more so
yeah that's exciting I mean there's
gonna be a helicopter on Mars yeah I
mean like it's it's weird because you
like you got to think about several
different things when you're designing a
helicopter on Mars first there's less
gravity so it's easier to fly on Mars
but also there's way less air so it's
harder to fly because of course you like
when you're flying you're pushing
against all the molecules in the
atmosphere but on Mars you've got like a
hundred times fewer molecules in the
atmosphere so you have to have bigger
rotors even though you have less gravity
to pull against so yeah they're figuring
it out and and there will be no way to
test precisely how effective are good at
its job it will be until it's there
because we won't be able to fly it on a
place that's exactly like Mars until
it's there but luckily science is there
to help
that is exciting Hank somewhat less
exciting is the news from AFC Wimbledon
so Hank as you well know Lyle Taylor the
montserrat Ian Messi I would argue the
greatest striker in the history of the
nation of Montserrat is likely to move
on from AFC Wimbledon it seems likely
he's been offered a contract and the
silence is deafening one can't in any
way fault Lyle for this football our
careers
our brief you don't make a lot of money
in the third tier of English football if
you have a chance to go make more of
course you have to further your family
and everything and also while Taylor is
one of the central reasons why AFC
Wimbledon are still a third tier English
football team so very very grateful to
him if indeed as it appears this is his
last season but weirdly the most recent
rumor about Lisle Taylor not that I
follow Twitter football rumors too too
much but I did I do I do follow them
have him going potentially to Lincoln
City which is a team in the fourth tier
of English football now potentially they
could pay a lot more money because
Lincoln City have some have some money
um and it may be that you know that's
where the money and the opportunity is
and so that's where he ends up going but
I personally would be a little bummed
out to see Lyle Taylor in the fourth
tier of English football I just I don't
think he should drop down to Ligue 2 I
think he should either be at a League
One club that has a really good chance
of moving up to the championship or he
should be in in the championship so
we'll see but I meanwhile has been such
a great player he is the fact that on a
team that scored very few goals he was
still you know up there in terms of goal
tally in in Ligue 1 as a whole speaks to
his talent and his commitment I mean he
said at the end of the season this team
is not going to get relegated on my
watch which I thought was a real
statement of intent and he meant it and
he he's not the only reason we stayed up
obviously but he's a big part of it so
it looks like Lyle Taylor will be
leaving but for where but for where and
also what are you going to replace him
with does he free up a bunch of money no
I mean he frees up a little money he
frees up a little money but not a ton of
money and it yeah I think it'll be
difficult I don't think it will be easy
to replace him
but hope is the thing with feathers Hank
yes if eclis the Sparrow with others
sparrow with feathers it's also your
your dad Graham dad as a hawk John you
know the way that you feel about AFC
Wimbledon really reminds me of how I
feel about turtles I like turtles I just
it's uh I haven't talked about it a lot
but I do I really do so John what was
your phrase of the week what was your
phrase of the week was it eventually I
like turtles uh yeah it was maybe good
made that a little harder on you I know
we talked about animals through the head
you had a couple opportunities what my
phrase do I died have no idea eskimo
kisses that's right it was yes
Oh was that a fake yeah it was
completely fake whatever your name
eskimo kisses way the world is so much
better now
oh no my real my real high school
username was way worse than that I wish
you'd been eskimo kisses but alas are
you gonna tell are you gonna tell it to
me are you gonna make make me god no no
let's move on Hank what did we learn
today we learned that looking down from
space the aliens are thinking well
they're there they're not doing it
perfect but they're doing it definitely
thinking they're not doing it perfect we
going that countertop dishwashers are
not a good birthday present unless the
person you're getting them for wants
them we learned a bit about late arrival
restaurant etiquette and of course we
learned that if a Hawk is following you
all the time it's just your grandpa this
podcast is edited by Nicholas Jenkins
it's produced by rosianna halse rojas
and shared and Gibson our head of
community and communications it's
Victoria bon giorno the music to you
hearing at the beginning and the end of
this podcast is from the great
gunnarolla you can find us at Hank green
on Twitter and John Green on Twitter and
also email us at Hank and John at
gmail.com
your questions you really appreciate
everybody who sends in those good good
questions and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]